place à notre série à voir à 20 ans dans
les années 2020 rencontre ce soir avec
mila une footballeuse qui évolue dans
l'équipe réservistes du dfco elle nous
explique comment elle arrive à concilier
à sport de haut niveau et études son
portrait avec ben bagués et sylvain
billau
ces lieux c'est dur
c'est dur d'avoir 20 en 2011 c'est tout
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle milla teixeira j'ai
20 ans je suis joueuse de foot au dfco
est arbitre et je suis étudiante en 3e
année d'économie à l'université de
bourgogne franche comté
[Musique]
j'ai commencé le foot j'avais 14 ans
c'était à dole dans le jura et ensuite
j'ai évolué dans un plus grand club
c'était au jura de loin j'ai voulu
m'engager dans le football parce que
j'avais une relation très particulière
avec mes cousins déjà quand j'étais
petit et quand on faisait des réunions
de famille bas on faisait beaucoup de
matchs de foot donc j'ai voulu me lancer
dans le foot pour pouvoir rivaliser
contre quand on se voyait j'ai évolué
dans une équipe de garçons quand j'étais
la seule fille dans mon équipe et donc
au début c'était difficile j'ai eu du
mal à me faire apprécier par les garçons
c'est à dire que vous sortez sortez des
entraînements le garçon je rentrais chez
moi je pleurais je me sentais mal dans
l'environnement où je m'entraînais et
maintenant et c'est derrière moi j'ai
réussi à passer le cap
mon plus beau souvenir dans le foot
c'était il ya trois ans quand je jouais
en u19 nationale pour monter en élite
c'est à dire dans la phase supérieure
par un grand exploit on a réussi à
gagner 1 0 contre lyon chez elle qui
lyon est une très grande une très grande
équipe je suis devenu arbitre
par attachement à mon ancien club le
jura de loi ils avaient besoin d'un
arbitre parce que il ya une loi c'est à
dire qu'on est obligé d'avoir autant un
nombre d'arbitrés dans le club pour que
le club puisse fonctionner correctement
au fur et à mesure j'ai pris du plaisir
ça m'a montré une autre image du foot je
suis pas actrice du match mais c'est moi
qui dirige le match
donc là je suis devant mon université là
où je suis mes cours je suis contente
aujourd'hui un gros soleil sur la fac du
coup ça fait plaisir quand je suis
arrivé à l'université c'était vraiment
compliqué d'assimiler les deux mais avec
un temps d'adaptation sadaf surtout que
en fait l'université ils ont mis en
place un statut et pep's c'est à dire un
statut pour les joueurs et joueuses de
haut niveau qui fait qu' on peut adapter
nos entraînements à nos cours sachant
que pour moi je pense que c'est plus
intéressant à mon âge de aussi faire
autant des études que de jouer au foot
c'est important parce que le foot ça
reste comme instable c'est à dire que si
dans la vie à une grosse blessure qui
arrivent au foot ça veut dire que ben le
foot ça va s'écrouler donc il est
important d'avoir des études derrière
pour se donner une porte de sortie
et en effet moi j'ai plus trois contes
et des caves ou le même esprit il a
décidé d'arrêter j'aime pas le terme
mais rami mais je dirais que c'est celle
qui se retrouve ce qui se rapproche le
plus d'une meilleure amie pour moi je
pouvais on est super fusionnelle si j'ai
un problème celle que j'appelle si
j'avais quelque chose à raconter celle
que j'appelle du coup voilà vous on
discute on s'amuse on peut même ne rien
faire en fait même quand je fais rire
avec elle je passe un bon moment donc
reste on peut tout vendre le quotidien
c'est une fille ultra speed fin j'ai
même jamais vu dormir donc elle trouve
toujours le temps de tout faire je me
demande comment elle fait mais elle
trouve toujours le temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais là c'est une joueuse très
intéressant qu'un tempérament que
j'apprécie pourquoi parce que c'est une
fille qui arrive à être leader dans un
groupe qui arrive à mener les troupes
humainement voilà donc pour la preuve et
les capitaines cette année elle est
capable d'être très objective c'est une
fille qui est travailleuse et qui est
persévérante c'est dur d'avoir 20 ans
mais je pense que la vie de tous les
jours fait qu'on a des amis on a des
passions et que avant 20 ans ça devient
de plus en plus facile et qu'on s'adapte
plus facilement
dans 20 ans je me vois dans une grande
entreprise en train de travailler et pas
sur un terrain de football